هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه المعروفه
اختصارا بافاد هي مؤسسه اغاثه تاسست عام
2009 واسندت اليها مهمه تنسيق جهود البحث
والانقاذ وتقديم المساعدات في الزلازل
والفيضانات وحرائق الغابات وغيرها من
حالات الطوارئ وعواقبها اصبحت افاد منذ
عام 2018 تابعه لوزاره الداخليه التركيه
بعد ان ظلت سنوات تحت اشراف رئيس الحكومه
طنشه المؤسسه داخل تركيا وخارجها حيث
اطلعت بدور اساسي خلال زلزال ازمير عام
2020 وفيضانات منطقه شمال البحر الاسود
عام 2021
وخارجيا نسقت افاد جهود اغاثه مختلفه لا
سيما في شمال شرق سوريا تضم المؤسسه اكثر
من سبعه الاف عنصر ينتشرون في نحو 80
تركيه لكنها ايضا تستقطب متطوعين بلغ
عددهم بعد الزلزال الاخير نحو 700 الف
متطوع وقد اصبحت افاد في السنوات الاخيره
اكثر انتشارا واقرب الى محتاج خدماتها اذ
وضع التطبيقات طوارئ للابلاغ عن الحوادث
كما عززت شركتها مع عده جهات اغاثه خارجيه
عبر اتفاقيات تعاون وستشكل كارثه الزلزال
الاخير وتبعاتها اختبارا مهما لمؤسسه افاد
من حيث قدرتها على الاستجابه السريعه
للكوارث الكبرى ونجاعه دورها